[Musique]
faisait rencontré dans le quartier ça a
été le coup de foudre
depuis huit jours je m'attache à tous
pas marqué bon ça suffit j'appelle mon
mari les sources cet imbécile de côté
voulez vous on mari un imbécile
les maris des femmes qui nous plaît ce
sont toujours des abbés ces exactions
montagnac quelle bonne surprise c'était
cette fois que chez moi vous le
franchement vous emmène au plus une
femme respectable il vous drague
pourquoi vous croyez avoir l'exclusivité
un homme que vous connaissez plus d'une
minute vingt josé la faim dans ce sens
c'est un bien à ma femme oui bonjour
bonjour oui pas sa mère
mais la veille la ville avait battu
tourne ta femme je sais pas si simple
moi qui croyais fidèles mais comme les
autres
si je surprends mon mari je suis avant
tout c'est fou j'ai une force au
conditionnel ou hossein
aujourd'hui quand vous n'êtes pas fan
tacticien aux jeunes auteurs
donc toi aujourd'hui jacqueline fehr dis
moi moi victoire c'est bien toi non
c'est jacky mais je te demande pas de
répondre j'ai jamais vu ça
mais toi je sais que je sais je sais que
tu sais que je sais nous savons que nous
savons que nous savons alors ça va j'ai
pas l'air d'un imbécile c'est évident
[Musique]